good morning Hank it's Friday the
beginning of the 9th annual project for
awesome you can head over to project
Rossum dot-com to find a link to the 48
hour livestream and info on donating and
all the amazing perks and of course to
watch and vote for project for awesome
videos your votes will determine where
much of the money raised is donated but
for the first half of the p4a we're
raising money for Save the Children and
the United Nations High Commission on
refugees so you're probably familiar
with the Syrian refugee crisis millions
of people have been forced to flee Syria
as a result of the horrifying civil war
there and both Save the Children and the
UNHCR providing massive support to
refugee camps from Turkey to Jordan to
Lebanon were more than a quarter of the
people currently living in the country
are refugees for these organizations
both work around the world and today I
want to focus on Ethiopia so since 2013
conflict in South Sudan has forced more
than 250,000 South Sudanese people to
flee to the gambelli region of Ethiopia
most have left with only whatever
belongings they can carry and often
ferry across the river border in canoes
this woman Sarah explained to a safe the
children employees succinctly why she
and her family had to leave the
government forces came and started
killing people so we ran away once they
get to Ethiopia most of these people
make their way to a camp where they then
wait to register as refugees more than
60% of the refugees arriving in gambelli
are children and many meet this man
johannes a child protection officer from
safe the children so Johannes works to
help these unaccompanied minors
including these boys all of whom arrived
in Ethiopia separated from their
families it's also a Hamas's job to make
sure that safe spaces are created and
maintained for children who live in the
camps within the camps safe the children
works to provide basic medical care
including measuring physical progress
- hopefully limit the stunting that can
lead to long-term physical and
intellectual disabilities and also to
provide kids with opportunities for play
and learning meanwhile the UNHCR works
to get food and basic shelter to the
refugees which is a massive task for a
perennial II underfunded organization
for instance this mother Mary explained
that there's no firewood to cook with in
the camps and no machines to mill grain
she said she wants to return to South
Sudan where her family was relatively
prosperous before the fighting broke out
but it's too dangerous I know it's easy
to feel hopeless in the face of these
complex challenges or to turn away from
the
the global refugee crisis is
overwhelming and it's easy to say that
this is not our problem that these boys
are not our boys but in the past few
years we've seen what human history has
shown us again and again that on this
planet there is no such thing as other
people's problems disease and poverty
and violence are shaped by political
borders but they cannot be controlled by
them whether it's Ebola or antibiotic
resistance or the civil war in Syria or
the refugees in Gambel oh we all lose
when we imagine that there are no
consequences to turning away from the
biggest human challenges these
unaccompanied children face an
exceptionally difficult future but it is
not a hopeless one
we know it isn't hopeless because we've
seen the success that humans have when
we come together to support and empower
the poorest and most disenfranchised
among us infant mortality has gone down
by half in the last 25 years the
percentage of kids in school has
skyrocketed an overall global poverty
has diminished but the global refugee
population hasn't been this high since
World War two and more than half of them
are children these refugees in
accordance with international law and
also with whatever higher law might
exist need to be protected we can't
afford to have a generation of
marginalized kids with no access to
health care or education and that's why
I don't see donations to organizations
like Save the Children or the UNHCR as
gifts I see them as investments we know
that healthier better educated kids
become happier more productive adults
and we know that the cycle of poverty
can be broken but these kids need our
investment so I hope you'll join me in
supporting them again on this the first
day of the project for awesome all the
donations to our charity the foundation
to decrease worldsuck will be split
between Save the Children and the UNHCR
and the money raised after that will go
to support charities chosen by you at
projectforawesome.com if you want to
make a donation directly to the
foundation you can do that by clicking
on this fancy new card that Google has
made there's no fee with the transaction
which is amazing and Google will match
every dollar donated through this card
up to $100,000 so please help us take
some of Google's money and again you can
go to project for awesome com to find
the fundraiser there and all the perks
and stuff and to follow along with the
livestream madness thank you happy
project for awesome and as we say in my
hometown of nerdfighteria don't forget
to be awesome
and screen Hank always says I should
make
and screen yes I know this video is more
than four minutes long and therefore I
will probably be punished I have
accepted this fate this is your last
chance to use the donation card unless
you rewind the video I will see you at
projectforawesome.com and in the
livestream bye